cycling groups and bike shops all across
the valley are also just
reeling from this tragedy today those
killed and those
injured this morning known to many as
very experienced
and very talented riders arko mana
joining us now live tonight just outside
of a las vegas city cyclery
near twain and town center with how the
community is reacting and remembering
those involved orca
well denise this is a devastating loss
for the local cycling community when a
cyclist dies in a vehicle crash
sculptures like this one
here in front of las vegas likely are
put up to honor them at the general
manager telling me
those who lost their lives today will
never be forgotten
we're just all numb we're just we're
processing it it's
it's been tough sean tyrone is at a loss
for words
he tells me some of his friends and
cycling buddies tragically died in
thursday's crash on the 95.
it's a pain the whole las vegas cycling
community is feeling right now
we're a tight-knit group here in town it
affects all of us as cyclists
personally you know we're all out there
every day you know enjoying our hobby
and and trying to
you know stay alive shawn is the general
manager at las vegas cyclery where this
ghost bike sculpture sits
he expects to see one at the site of
thursday's crash as these white bikes
are usually placed where cyclists have
died in car crashes
to raise awareness and just to remind
everyone that you know
there's not a text or a phone call or
anything
distraction wise that's worth somebody's
life the bike industry in las vegas is
definitely
hurting today dan county with mcgee's
bike shop tells me some of the people
killed were customers here and although
it's still unclear what exactly caused
the box truck to veer into the cyclists
one thing is for certain these were
highly skilled and safe riders
it sounds like everybody was doing the
right thing everybody was they had a
vehicle with them
maintaining a safe distance you know
they were using lights
they were on a ride in a route that they
had used before they're all experienced
riders there a lot of them are racers as
shawn comes to terms with what happened
he says
he's reminded of how precious life is
hug everyone you meet
because they might not be there tomorrow
the community is planning to hold a
vigil at this sculpture
this saturday to honor the cyclist
killed in today's crash
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now